les commerçants n'en peuvent plus à
paris dans le quartier de la goutte d'or
des affiches ont été placardées pour
alerter sur l'insécurité
aujourd'hui la goutte d'or c'est un
secteur où se mélangent différentes
cultures
une métamorphose initiée dans les années
60 sont beaux quartiers j'aime bien ça
la goutte d'or un nom en référence aux
anciennes vignes situées au nord de
paris
à partir des années 60 une nouvelle
population s'y installent
majoritairement des immigrés du nord de
l'afrique
en témoigne cette jeune institutrice
tout juste installé dans le quartier en
c'était un peu comme un village un
village un peu étranger dans paris le
boulanger le boucher était arabe
les inscriptions sur les boutiques
étaient faits en arabe là vraiment je me
sentais pas tout à fait chez moi la
goutte d'or devient un endroit populaire
et pluriculturelle années 70 les marchés
exotiques côtoient les boutiques de
textile mais très vite le quartier se
dégradent les logements deviennent
vétuste au début des années 80 de plus
en plus d'appartements sont à vendre
si la situation où on connaît les
difficultés actuelles c'est en toute
priorité dû à la politique d'abandon des
pouvoirs publics de la majorité depuis
des dizaines d'années dans ce quartier
de la goutte d'or
pour y remédier un vaste plan de
réhabilitation est lancé dès 1983 et
bien la rénovation des quartiers où la
demande d'apple entendre
si certains sont pour d'autres contraire
ne veulent pas quitter le quartier
environ famille s'ils vont m'emmener
c'est par exemple la république ce qui
va me colette comme que je suis en arabe
je préfère vivre avec elle avec ma
patrie autres qu'ici dans le quartier à
quartier a ravi si la rénovation se
termine en 1997 soit quatorze ans après
au début des années 2000 malgré cette
réhabilitation l'endroit connaît
régulièrement des problèmes d'insécurité
dans la rue trafic de stupéfiants et
commerces illicites se mêlent aux
violences une association tirait déjà la
sonnette d'alarmé
je ne veux pas accepter que dans mon
quartier dans ma ville il se passe des
choses comme ça ça n'est pas tolérable
malgré ces problèmes d'insécurité le
quartier se jean trifi lentement au
milieu des années 2010 des restaurants
des fleuristes mais aussi des bars en
plein air voit le jour fassin pas très
original puis dans un quartier comme le
nôtre ça change vraiment quoi
aujourd'hui
la goutte d'or reste l'un des secteurs
les moins chers de paris en moyenne en
2019 le prix au mètre carré atteignez
tout de même les 7400 euros
[Musique]